you been up to anything
nope yeah the only thing Joey's been up
to is
shaving yeah I had to I had to shave
because uh I had a Halloween party last
week uh where I invited a couple of my
friends we do it every year at our house
obviously we uh cosplay or you know
costumes or whatever and I were Shaggy
and Scooby-Doo this year so yeah so a
had the fullon onesie and I fully
committed to the shagy bit I shaved
everything except for the go here it was
[__] disgusting i l like if Fred
Durst had a baby with the lead singer a
Smashmouth it it looked [__] gross
was it worth it yeah fun time yeah it
was really fun um yeah it's always good
fun um I don't know what happened in
Shia I heard the I heard they see the
massive signs though saying [__] off
yeah they're saying like we will do some
bad things if you do bad things yeah
they should be a did this gigabrain move
where they were like we're going to tell
people that they can't drink alcohol but
there's no punishment if doing and then
they started boarding up stations uh to
stop people from meaning up but it just
made it people it made it more congested
yeah so it made it more dangerous yeah
which is the most Japanese move I've
ever seen in my life they're like let's
fix a problem oh we just made it worse I
think it's just like there's just such a
disconnect uh between like all the
people in Japan and the Japanese
government and like just allowing
younger people to express themselves and
like I don't I think getting drunk and
all crazy in uh in the Tokyo is not not
great or the best way to do it but I
feel like just clamping down on it and
trying to get rid of it entirely is not
the move here no um you know and I I
think yeah obviously there was some
there was some bad apples in it but I
think generally it all went it all went
okay except people when they were trying
to flip cars over yeah but I don't I
don't think like evacuate all the trucks
get them out of here they've been cuz a
lot of people were saying that it was
because of the Korean um the disaster
happened but they they've been trying to
do this for years now they've been
trying it um and this is the year where
they really try to do stuff but this
weird kind of rule where you can't drink
but they're not going to do anything
they'll just have a man come around and
Shout at you but he can't do anything
well we're actually filming this on the
31st of October so it's going to be
interesting to see what happens in the
next couple of hours be I just it's just
dude I feel like they've just gone about
it the most Japanese way possible and
that is the worst way possible like I
feel like they could have done this in a
in a few better ways uh but like having
no laws pass and asking people not to
drink is just never going to work stop
having fun there's no fun allowed in the
city and I I SP to am right I SP to a
lot of foreign people who just seem to
not care which I think is just going to
make all this a lot of the foreign
Japanese relations that have been bad
already recently the foreign Japanese
Rel just making it even worse whenever I
see the Japanese uh News videos popping
up and they they cuz they love Japanese
news loves doing this they love finding
a foreigner drinking alcohol
around there and being like look look at
them not following the rules we the and
all the comments are like wow you Auto
translate Japanese like wow classic
foreigners can't follow rules here and
it's like Jesus Christ it's like no we
can follow rules we follow rules that
make sense to follow you know yeah and I
also think that just having a news crew
only show some foreign people who when
it's not it's [__] just foreign
people who are doing this Japanese
people are also doing this never mind
the fact that those four Dudes who
flipped the truck last year were all
they were all Japanese so it's such
[__] they do this and it's very
frustrating sometimes that because they
know that this does well and it gets
engagement on the on the Japanese new
sites if they if they purposely blame at
the mouth so frustrating because then
you when when these these cases that
come along earlier like the ones that
with the actual Foreigner is a piece of
[__] it it it makes them feel like they
are right yeah for this this Prejudice
they
have yeah oh it's frustrating we'll see
we'll see what happens in the next
couple of hours Shia might be
quiet or or they could be about seven I
think it's going to be bad I think it's
going to be because they they've bought
it off way too much and it's they've
made Shia station actually uh like more
dangerous to get around there cuz they
bought it off as if it wasn't already
[__] it's so bad yeah I don't know
why they so it's such a such a dumb idea
what they did yeah is it is it just me
oh has like even has the want to come to
visit Japan just like increased as like
in the past few years like I think is
the Catalyst for that because I felt
like there was interest before a little
podcast called trash I do I I I
genuinely think that like what what
we're doing and a bunch of other Tik
toks and all stuff just showing Japan
off all the time has helped has has made
it so much more it's all a free
advertisement of Japan by foreigners who
come to you cannot go five minutes on
Tik Tok without getting recommended a
Japanese food video it's not possible
it's not possible do you think it's
because we're in Japan so we getting
recommend that cuz I can never tell
because
it's so hard to tell because like have
you ever like logged into YouTube with a
completely fresh account or like
incognito mode and you're like I do not
recognize any of these people and they
have like 26 million views I would I
would say we probably are getting
recommended them more cuz we are
inclined to watch that but a lot of
these Tik toks have 2 to 5 million views
and that can't just be the xat
population around that's more than the X
yeah and it's weird cuz like um I did a
I made some shorts just for YouTube and
I did one where I um there was this
there's a a store called onigiri Bongo I
don't know if you heard of it it's this
onigiri place where people line up 5
hours for oh yes I heard it's [__]
ridiculous people like up to 5 hours
it's normally a 2 hour wait um and uh I
found out when I was looking at the
website that you could just call up uh
obviously if do in Japanese but you
could call up and just say like oh y
yaku deimar you could reserve uh a spot
in the line no no you can doaku Mo
muskar oh hi saw this here and then you
just say like tomorrow 11:00 a.m. can I
have this and they're like yeah so I
yeah I just saw on the website it said
that you could call up and Reserve to go
and I was thinking well onigiri is
probably the most to go food of all time
you don't sit down for it is a it is a
strictly tog go food so I was like oh
okay well easy so I I was like there's
no way it's this easy so I call up I say
hey can I come pick it up tomorrow at at
11:00 and they were like yet so I order
I go in and I felt I felt like I was
doing something wrong I like this's this
long line like look at this far in a no
no dude so there's a line of like 60
people right right all Japanese yeah uh
and I go up and I'm like I don't know
where to go cuz i' my first time coming
here I'm looking around I'm like I think
I just go right to the front yeah and uh
as I'm going in this guy goes H and I
was like oh mo i and he's like oh oh
like a guy in the line was GNA like tell
me I was cutting and so cuz I saw
someone else just do it right as I was
about to do it so I was like oh okay go
up I just say my name they give me my
rice balls and I was like oh [__] that
took 10 seconds I've hacked the system
yeah and I was like why why is everyone
waiting 5 hours in L so I made the CH
being like this isuck people waiting 5
hours and you can just do an evance
because that kind of information is not
available on yah that's true that's true
but then which is what they but then I
started getting these comments from
people who are like classic [__]
foreign tourist doesn't want to Wai in
line makes the Japanese people wait
longer and I was like no they're doing
it to them [__] themselves I was like
what the [__] bro these people these
comments know Japanese people love
waiting it's like a [__] Pas time for
them I thought the British loved a queue
but man the Japanese and so yeah I got
like a bunch of weird ones where they
were like uh uh there's just a bunch of
people who are these very weird people
who are I guess obsessed with Japan Who
come out of the woodwork occasionally
and just want to slant on you for doing
anything even remely differently
meanwhile you look into them and it's
like Nigel from Arkansas who's never
left his country before and just read a
lot of [__] about Japan I'm like stop
well you know a a lot of people you know
my my Japanese is not fluid at all I'm
like baby conversation level but you're
a bit better than oh I appreciate that
but the amount of doors that open up
that I realized that when one I wasn't
afraid of talking on the phone and sound
like an idiot and being able to like
book things it opened up so many doors
definitely being able to do that and
confidently like call them up cuz I'm
like this kind of conversation I'm
pretty sure I can handle um cuz I was
like I'm going to ask can I reserve
they're going to say yes when I'm going
to tell them the time and they're going
to be like all right what do you want so
that's how it went yeah and I nailed it
and I went and got it and it was great
it was so delicious I wouldn't wait 5
hours but it is by far the best on a
Gear ever had about oh really if I if I
was was a like unloaded the secret and
everyone's going to be fting up for
[__] res now there's going to be a
line for
reservations cuz I think they make it
the morning off before they open or like
maybe later in the night but either way
it was amazing like it was really good
and it was these things are [__] huge
they're like twice the size of normal
onir and I ate three and I was I was
dying it was so good a kilo of rice so
yeah if you if you do go you know and
you got like a day trip planned it's
like SE seven or eight of you guys just
go pick up a bunch sweet great